après une condamnation à 18 ans de
prison une grâce présidentielle
partielle omar raddad poursuit son
combat pour obtenir une réhabilitation
une étape importante a été franchie
aujourd'hui puisque l'avocat général de
la cour de cassation a demandé la
révision du procès la décision a été
mise en délibéré sylvain lequesne
christophe monteil deux ans qu omar
raddad attend ce moment
cet après-midi les justices se pencher
pour la première fois sur la demande de
révision de son procès une procédure qui
s'annonce très longue
la commission de révision devait
déterminer aujourd'hui si de nouveaux
éléments étaient susceptibles de jeter
un doute sur sa culpabilité
avant de transmettre ou non le dossier à
la cour de révision seule habilitée à
ordonner un nouveau procès pour cette
première étape
la commission a livré le résultat de
nouvelles enquêtes sur ces lettres de
sang retrouvé près de ghislaine marchal
selon ces nouvelles analyses rien
n'assure que la victime est écrit elle
même le fameux omar m'a tuer accusant le
jardinier en outre des traces d'un adn
masculin qui ne correspond pas celui
d'omar raddad ont été retrouvés mêlés au
sang de la victime
mais ces traces n'ont pu être identifiés
ces révélations et d'autres
interrogations concernant notamment la
date du crime ont néanmoins jeter un
doute sur la culpabilité d'omar raddad
des doutes qui ont amené l'avocat
général a demandé la transmission du
dossier à la corderie d'histoire oui
parce que si à la fin je me suis
retrouvé d'accord avec monsieur l'avocat
général c'est bien qu un dossier on
s'est pas rencontrés auparavant il ya un
dossier il ya des expertises
ces exercices sans nouvelles le renvoie
devant pas le renvoi devant une nouvelle
juridiction c'est pour vérifier tout ça
nous dit son pack ici la preuve devait
apporter de l'innocence
nous disons qu'ici là on doit apporter
des éléments qui suscitent un doute et
une discussion
omar raddad est resté silencieux tout au
long de l'audience le regard fixe
lorsque l'avocat général a estimé que
ces nouveaux éléments
créée en août un des miens la décision
de renvoyer ou non le dossier à la cour
de révision a été mise en délibéré au 25
juin
omar raddad sera alors si sa
réhabilitation concrètement être
envisagée